heute lässt tesla die bombe platzen nach
monaten der verschiebungen und
peinlicher tweets von elenas der das
erscheinen immer wieder verschob wird
die neue version der software für
autonomes fahren
die durch künstliche intelligenz
gesteuert wird erscheinen und wird sie
eine bittere enttäuschung oder wird sie
bahnbrechend und eine revolution für die
künstliche intelligenz klicks um science
im future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los ist herzlich
willkommen
dieser tag könnte in die geschichte
eingehen und zwar gar nicht als ein
meilenstein für das autonome fahren
sondern als großer schritt für die
künstliche intelligenz und da scheint es
einerseits seinen terminplan überhaupt
nicht einhalten zu können aber
andererseits an einem ganz großen ding
zu arbeiten die software für das
autonome fahren will self driving fs die
auf deutsch vollständiges autonomes
fahren erscheint nach monatelangen
verschieben in der version 9 beta und
diese software versteht etwas aus
unserem alltagsleben nämlich verkehr und
mit verstehen ist ja tatsächlich all das
begreifen all dessen was dort passieren
kann das ist so ein gar nicht so komplex
weil es nahezu überall auf der welt sehr
gut geregelt ist aber andererseits ist
es fehlerhaft und zudem nehmen menschen
die fehler machen
am verkehr teil ist es also gar nicht
lösbar wie manche sagen oder ist es
lösbar wyhlen maske immer wieder
beteuert irgendwann heute ist zwischen
freitag und samstag soll die software
erscheint und wir werden klarer sehen
zwar ist sie immer noch eine beta
version aber sie soll einen großen
schritt in richtung einer wirklich voll
funktionsfähigen software seien sehr
viele um nicht zu sagen die meisten
experten experten bezweifeln dass tesla
das hinbekommt sie weisen auf die
konkurrenz sind die wärme und cruz schon
weiter seien sie bezweifeln dass ihnen
macht das autonome fahren ausschließlich
mit videokameras ohne andere sensoren
hinbekommt das sind tatsächlich starke
argumente
wenn man allerdings genauer hinsieht
dann sieht das nicht ganz so gut aus
vail fährt nur in einem ganz bestimmten
bereich in der stadt phoenix in den usa
liegt nur sehr ungern links ab was auch
die größte herausforderung ist und
selbst mit diesen einschränkungen
stecken die fahrzeuge gerne mal in für
sie unlösbaren situationen fest
und bleiben einfach mitten im verkehr
stehen und ähnlich sieht es bei kues aus
ihnen macht sieht das klar ganz anders
er vermutet eine sackgasse bei der
konkurrenz denn die vielen sensoren
bieten keine klarheit sondern im
gegenteil sie sind gefährlich mit mass
fahrzeuge die zum beispiel radar
verwenden verursachen gerne mal
gefährliche notbremsung das berichten
fahrerinnen und fahrer von tesla die
norder einsetzen aber auch von anderen
automarken das problem
rader sucht und findet nur hindernisse
und hat keine ahnung worum es sich
handelt und da kommt es schon mal zu
großen missverständnissen sprich es gibt
durchaus eine wahrscheinlichkeit dass
mast da tatsächlich richtig liegt wie
der mensch kann die fst software mit den
acht kameras an bord eines testers ein
realistisches 3d umgebung sub bild
erstellen und verfügt damit sogar über
mehr informationen als der mensch weil
die kameras in jeder sekunde die gesamte
umgebung abtasten und es gibt noch einen
riesigen pluspunkt teslas super
computing
denn wie der chef der abteilung für
künstliche intelligenz ki bei tesla
andere cuppartie vor kurzem erklärte
verfügt tesla über einen der schnellsten
supercomputer der welt es ist der
trainingscomputer mit dem tesla die full
safe driving software entwickelt und
seine daten sind absolut beeindruckend
laut cuppartie ist es der fünf
schnellsten supercomputer der welt
dieser supercomputer ist das zentrale
element der künstlichen intelligenz ki
bei tesla und ki wird nicht programmiert
sondern lernt und das passiert auf
diesem supercomputer dazu werden
zunächst videos aus der tesla
fahrzeugflotte hochgeladen und gelabelt
hier sitzen so genannte label und sehen
sich die videos an und machen kästchen
um fahrzeuge und sagen der künstlichen
intelligenz damit was das ist was sie da
in den kameras sieht und das ist gar
nicht so unkompliziert da auch das
verhalten des fahrers oder der fahre mit
gelähmt wird wechselt das fahrzeug
gleich die spur und erfährt es nur
zufällig zu dicht an der
fahrbahnmarkierung will diese
fußgängerin jetzt noch schnell über die
straße oder bleibt sie stehen fällt
dieser fahrradfahrer gleich hin für all
diese fahrzeuge und situationen gibt es
klassen in die sie einsortiert werden
und daraus lernt dann die künstliche
intelligenz auf dem supercomputer mit
unzähligen beispielen und kann so am
ende viel besser beurteilen was
passieren wird als wir menschen
das können und diese software reagiert
dann entsprechend und eben im besten
fall besser als wir menschen das ist das
was ihnen maske meint wenn er von 4d
spricht die tester fsd software ist in
der lage durch die acht kameras nicht
nur den raum in 3d zu erfassen sondern
aufgrund ihrer riesigen erfahrung durch
die vielen daten aus den millionen tesla
fahrzeugen auch in die zukunft zu sehen
und dieses lernen geschieht dann eben
auf dem supercomputer und nur ein extrem
leistungsfähiger computer ist in der
lage diese datenmengen dann zu erfassen
und zu verarbeiten und der aktuelle
supercomputer ist dabei sogar nur ein
zwischenschritt tesla baut gerade durch
und wenn die informationen durch tester
richtig sind wird er eine rechenleistung
von einem extra flop erreichen
das ist nicht nur zehn mal schneller als
der bisherige rechner das wäre auch der
schnellste supercomputer der welt und es
würde damit bedeuten dass tesla die
entwicklung der ssds software zehnfach
beschleunigen kann mehr zum thema gibt
es übrigens in meinem neuen buch tesla
oder wie ihren mast die elektromobilität
revolutioniert daran gibt es noch mehr
verblüffende erkenntnisse über die
elektro auto energie und jetzt auch
keine firma wer es also als erstes in
der hand halten möchte sollte es jetzt
vorbestellen gibt es überall wo es gute
bücher gibt oder hier also in jeder
guten buchhandlung oder ihr und habe nie
mit einem klick wird tesla also mit der
fsd software erfolgreich sein wird dass
jetzt ein jahr bahnbrechendes ereignis
die veröffentlichung der fsd beta 9
lässt sich spricht einiges dafür und
einiges dagegen dass die software
wirklich jede verkehrssituation in jedem
land der welt meistert ist eigentlich
unwahrscheinlich allerdings ist die
aktuelle beta-version jetzt schon so
ziemlich beeindruckenden dingen fähig
zum beispiel biegt sie links ab in den
gegenverkehr
dass es wohl mit die größte
herausforderung für eine ki und die irs
die software beherrscht sie bereits
grundsätzlich und immer öfter wurde von
fahrten vollkommen ohne eingriff
berichtet aber wird das je ganz ohne
eingriff funktionieren darüber scheiden
sich die geister
tatsächlich könnte das unmöglich sein es
spricht einiges dafür dass es bereiche
geben wird wo die fsd software.de noch
lange nicht ihr ziel erreichen könnte
baustellen sind so ein fall
hier konkurrieren verschiedene
fahrbahnmarkierungen miteinander und
manchmal sind sie auch komplett weg wie
soll eine software da wissen dass die
fahrspuren einheiten
die gar nicht existieren aber was diese
überlegungen klar machen
es werden immer weniger sehr spezielle
situationen die die fst software nur
schwer beherrschen kann und vielleicht
werden sie ja doch in absehbarer zeit
gelöst bis dahin wird sie eine beta
version bleiben und nur mit der
kontrolle des fahnen eingesetzt werden
dürfen insofern sind die diskussionen
der letzten monate und wochen nur
verständlich und testlabor taxis werden
dann noch etwas auf sich warten lassen
allerdings könnten sie dann mit der
unterstützung von dem supercomputer
schneller kommen als erwartet
es bleibt also spannend es schon zu
wenig gesagt es bleibt elektrisierend ja
und wie spannend das thema ist und wie
elektrisieren das könnt ihr auf 240
seiten mit vielen bildern nachlesen
tesla oder wie ihre maske
elektromobilität revolutioniert gibt es
überall was gute bücher gibt oder hier
unter dem link am besten jetzt
vorbestellen
dann habt ihr es als erster und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran